Tuesday July 9 are you ready America the  international sensation love Islands is  coming to CBS and look at what we've got  for you America it is time to meet the  Islanders let's do it I'm Kara I can be  a little bit of a flirt when it comes to  a competing for girl that keep is so  real I definitely keep boys on their  toes find me a man please I think I have  a good intuition when it comes to  finding the right girl I am a real  cowboy I am a diva  that's just how we should be I know I'm  a catch the guys can't go Smee there's  nowhere to hide it's all about the Bucks  it's all about  I'm really excited to be here I'm  excited for the men I do wake up looking  like this - the shirt and the pants it's  gonna be one hot summer love island five  nights a week series premiere CBS  Tuesday July 9  [Music]